All praise is due to Allah. We praise Him, seek His help, ask for His forgiveness, seek His guidance, and
repent to Him. We seek refuge in Allah from the evil of
our own souls and from the evil of our deeds. He whom Allah guides is truly guided, and he whom He leaves astray will
find no protector or guide. On behalf of the scholars of
the Levant, the scholars of
Syria have issued a
fatwa permitting a
Syrian woman to ask a
capable Muslim man to
clothe and shelter
her. It is
permissible for her to ask him to enter into a
contract of ownership (mahlamah) so that she becomes
his property. The evidence for this is the saying of the Messenger of Allah (peace and blessings be upon him), narrated
by Anas (may Allah be pleased with him), who said: The Messenger of
Allah (peace and blessings be upon him) said: “Among the signs of
the Hour is that knowledge will be taken away and
ignorance will prevail,” until he said, “until a man has a single woman in charge of him.” The one in charge
here is the one who manages his affairs, and they become his
slaves and female slaves. And
in the hadith narrated by Bukhari, “A man will be seen
followed by 40 women,” due to the scarcity of
men and the abundance of women.
And in his saying (peace and blessings be upon him): “When tribulation becomes widespread,
Allah will distinguish His allies until a man is followed by 50
women saying, ‘O servant of Allah, protect me, O servant of Allah!’”
God is my witness, and in the narration she says to him, “Marry me.” This is a
solution to the issue of
displacement
affecting our people in Syria, where the displaced women
in
Syria
find no one to cover
their expenses or ensure their safety and
security. Therefore, it is permissible for them to request to
enter into a marriage contract of ownership of a slave woman,
whereby this man becomes her master and she becomes his slave woman,
and the rulings concerning ownership of slave women, which
God Almighty confirmed in His saying, “Except with
their wives or those whom their right hands possess, for indeed, they are not to be blamed,” apply to her. The
legal ruling is that
the woman becomes subject to the ruling of ownership of a slave woman, as we have
explained in these proofs.
Firstly, there is a scarcity of men and an abundance of women, as
Imam al-
Nawawi said. As for the reason for the scarcity of men and the abundance of women, it is the
wars and fighting that will occur at the end of
time and the accumulation of battles. We have explained that we have
entered the end of time because of what God
Almighty mentioned in His saying, “Then when the final promise comes, We will bring you forth in a mixed crowd.”
Therefore, we
issue a fatwa to the Syrian woman who wants to marry a
Muslim man in a marriage contract of ownership of a slave woman, whereby he
becomes her master and she becomes his slave woman.  This
contract requires only that the woman
menstruate and
register it with the sheikhs, a
notary public, a Syrian judge, or a
judge in the country she has emigrated to. It can be registered
in civil or
Sharia courts, or announced through
known media.
After the woman becomes his property, having said, "I give
myself to you by right of possession," she becomes his mistress, and he
becomes her master. She becomes his slave, his servant, and his slave. He is responsible for her clothing, her protection, her health and
physical well-being, and her maintenance, as well as the
maintenance of anyone under her care, such as a child,
sibling, or other relative. These individuals
fall under the category of those under right of possession
after the
woman declares, "I give myself to you." This is in exchange for a known sum of money
paid by the
capable Muslim man to cover her needs. It is permissible to
open a bank account for her, ensuring this sum is
available to her whenever
needed. This sum covers her expenses,
clothing, housing, and other necessities.
Therefore, this fatwa is issued on behalf of
the scholars of the Levant, and we, by the permission of God
Almighty, will call upon the scholars of the Levant to adopt
it, for it is the only legitimate means
that guarantees the displaced Syrian woman, who has
no one but God, that she will not be
sexually exploited, humiliated, assaulted,
or taken advantage of through illegitimate means. May
God bless our Prophet Muhammad, his family, and his companions, and grant them abundant peace.